A birthday party from hell and the
most famous manhunt in history.
Critics thought these movies
were silver-screen gold. Did you?
As the only film on this list with a perfect
Metascore of 100, "Boyhood" has a lot of hype
to live up to. Directed and written by Richard
Linklater, "Boyhood" was filmed over the course
of an outstanding 12 years. Linklater began with
just an initial outline and wrote each section
of the characters' lives along the way. The result
is an authentic, visceral depiction of growing up.
The film follows Mason Evans, Jr. who at the
beginning of the film is just 6 years old.
The plot follows Mason through
the next dozen years of his life,
as he navigates family, romance and
everything else that comes with adolescence.
Ethan Hawke and Patricia Arquette co-star as
Mason's divorced parents, Mason Sr. and Olivia.
The film received a ton of accolades,
including six Academy Award nominations
and a Best Supporting Actress win for
Arquette. "Boyhood" received a massive
amount of praise from critics for the
beauty and remarkable nature of the movie.
"You're kind of weird, you know that?"
"Is that a compliment?"
"I don't know."
Barry Jenkins' "Moonlight"
holds a 96 score on Metacritic.
It is a film so good that it's hard to put
into words a description of its brilliance.
Not that that stopped critics from trying and
succeeding to explain just how mesmerizing the
film is, with various publications praising
its grand ambition and powerful message.
The story follows a young
gay Black man named Chiron
growing up in Miami through three distinct
periods of his life. It begins with Chiron
as a kid, who is confused by his desires and
sexuality. It moves on to his teenage years,
as he begins to come into himself more and even
has his first sexual experience. It concludes
with Chiron as a young adult, as he still
struggles deeply with accepting who he is.
Each actor takes on the role of Chiron
in their own ways, with their own power,
while at the same time seamlessly
sharing the same character. Of course,
Mahershala Ali's Oscar-winning turn
as the drug dealer Juan who becomes a
mentor and father figure to Chiron is
simply an unforgettable performance.
"You got it all right now. Alright?"
Set in 1970s Mexico City, Alfonso Cuarón's
"Roma" follows a young woman named Cleo who
works as a live-in maid for the middle-class
household of a couple named Sofia and Antonio,
their four children, and Sofia's mother. When
Cleo becomes pregnant, her boyfriend refuses to
acknowledge the baby. At the same time, Antonio
suddenly runs away with his young mistress.
As a result, Cleo finds herself bonding
more with Sofia and the rest of the family.
"Roma" holds a Metacritic score of 96, with
many critics deeming it an intimate portrait
and a grandiose piece of filmmaking. The
word masterpiece was thrown around by more
than one outlet. Upon watching
"Roma," it's clear to see why.
Written and directed by Kenneth
Lonergan, "Manchester by the Sea"
tells the story of Lee Chandler who,
after the death of his brother Joe,
learns that he has been made the
sole guardian of his nephew, Patrick.
Upon returning to Manchester-by-the-Sea,
the fishing village where he's from,
to take care of Patrick, Lee is forced to face his
traumatic past and his estranged ex-wife Randi.
The film was nominated for a huge string of
awards, including six Academy Award nods in
almost all the major categories. Of the six,
Casey Affleck won for Best Actor and Lonergan
won for Best Original Screenplay. Both wins
likely align with the experience the viewer
has in watching the film: Lee's world is so
intricately constructed and Affleck takes on
the role with keen skill. These achievements
are reflected in its 96 score on Metacritic.
Based on the memoir "Twelve Years a Slave"
by Solomon Northup, this film adaptation and
Best Picture winner is a striking portrait of
a real man's horrific reality back in the years
before the Civil War. Written for the screen
by John Ridley and directed by Steve McQueen,
"12 Years a Slave" tells the story of a free Black
man named Solomon living in upstate New York,
where slavery is abolished. But when Solomon
is suddenly kidnapped, he gets sold back
into slavery, facing the cruelty of not only his
circumstances but of a brutal master named Edwin.
After 12 years of this life, Solomon
finally has the opportunity to escape.
Much of the film's praise
went directly to McQueen,
whose firm grasp on the subject and
presentation of this difficult storyline
is thoughtful and memorable enough for
a 96 score on Metacritic. Additionally,
the cast members do phenomenal work, making the
deep authenticity of the film even more nuanced
and compelling. Chiwetel Ejiofor received an
Oscar nomination for his portrayal of Solomon,
while Lupita Nyong'o won the Best
Supporting Actress for her role as Patsey.
"Cheers."
Carrying a film essentially on your own is no
small feat for an actor. But with "Gravity,"
lead actor Sandra Bullock proves herself
more than capable. Directed and co-written
by Alfonso Cuarón, "Gravity" centers on medical
engineer Dr. Ryan Stone, as she begins her first
in-space shuttle mission. Aided by veteran
astronaut Matt Kowalsky, their mission soon
goes disastrously wrong, putting them both in
imminent danger. With their shuttle destroyed,
the two quickly realize they're stranded in the
middle of space, and Ryan is soon left on her own.
Moviegoers who experienced "Gravity" were
likely not surprised when the film won
seven of the 10 Academy Awards it was nominated
for. It's the kind of visually ambitious film
that is bound to succeed in all of the technical
aspects, but the real impact of "Gravity" is
more than just a visual and auditory feat,
as evidenced by its Metacritic score of 96.
It's clear to see what Cuarón's intention for
"Gravity" was: to fully immerse the viewer in
the magical, if also terrifying, world
of deep space, right alongside Bullock.
"Either way, whichever way, no harm, no foul."
"Parasite" became the first non-English language
film to ever win the Academy Award for Best
Picture. However, even that groundbreaking feat
doesn't convey exactly how much of a triumph this
film from director Bong Joon-ho really is. In
what has been called a career best for Joon-ho,
"Parasite" will pull you in and surprise
you at every turn, even when you're sure you
have a grasp on what's happening. This isn't
even to mention the ultra sharp commentary,
themes, and symbolism constantly at play
that landed this a 96 score on Metacritic.
"Parasite" follows the struggling Kim family, who,
living in a semi-basement apartment, fold pizza
boxes for extra income to stay afloat. When the
Kims' son gets a job tutoring the daughter of the
wealthy Park family, the Kims scheme to all get
jobs in the Parks' affluent home. In a compelling
look into class inequality, greed and power, the
Kims' newly found comfort also becomes threatened.
While "Parasite" is a film that's difficult to
fully sum up, many critics have tried to analyze
its different messages. It has been referred
to as uncomfortable and uneasy to watch, but
it ultimately presents a story that has something
important to say and holds true to many people.
Written and directed by French filmmaker
Céline Sciamma, "Portrait of a Lady on
Fire" offers a personal look into the intimacy
between two lovers in a visually stunning slow
burn that earned a 95 score on Metacritic. Set
on an island off the coast of France in 1770,
the story follows a young painter who is
commissioned to paint the wedding portrait
of a rebellious soon-to-be bride. In the midst of
this assignment, they fall passionately in love.
A beautiful love story deserves beautiful visual
imagery, which is exactly what director Sciamma
and cinematographer Claire Mathon deliver.
The lead actors give excellent performances,
both individually and especially together.
Their chemistry leaps off the screen
and keeps you rooting for them even when you sense
that they only have a tragic ending ahead of them.
Based on the novel "The Price
of Salt" by Patricia Highsmith,
"Carol" was adapted by Phyllis Nagy for
the screen and directed by Todd Haynes.
Set in 1950s Manhattan, "Carol" follows the
romantic relationship between a middle-aged
woman in the midst of a messy divorce,
and a young aspiring photographer.
Both Cate Blanchett and Rooney Mara excel
in depicting two characters whose outer
lives have to differ from their inner feelings.
Getting to see their lives outside of each
other only makes their connection more palpable
once they do come together. The film
received a 94 score on Metacritic with
reviewers complimenting the chemistry of the
actors and the film's passionate love story.
"And I thought perhaps you
might like to come with me."
Mark Zuckerberg is one of the most
famous entrepreneurs out there today,
and the 95-scoring "The Social Network"
offers a peek behind the curtain of the
man behind the news headlines. Written by
Aaron Sorkin and directed by David Fincher,
"The Social Network" begins when Zuckerberg
was still a student at Harvard. From there,
we see the creation of Facebook from its
roots and how it led to Zuckerberg landing
on the receiving end of two major lawsuits
in relation to his growing social media site.
As one of the oldest films on this list,
we can say that "The Social Network" has
aged well since its release. Watching
it now, the observations seem more keen,
the writing just as sharp, and the depiction
of Zuckerberg all the more telling.
"I know. I'm totally psyched about this too."
The only documentary on this list with
a Metacritic tally of 95, "I Am Not Your
Negro" is a searing social critique based on the
unfinished manuscript "Remember This House" by
James Baldwin. It is narrated by Samuel L. Jackson
and adapted for the screen by director Raoul Peck.
Importantly, the film explores racism in
America through the lens of the deaths
of three of Baldwin's close friends: Medgar
Evers, Malcolm X and Martin Luther King, Jr.
In terms of documentaries, this one hits
all the marks of what a great one should be.
Beyond being a standout of its genre, it also
integrates the work of a literary great in
Baldwin. Ever-timely and ever-fascinating, it's a
shining example of the power of the documentary.
The attack on 9/11 is undoubtedly one of the
defining moments of recent history. It also
led to the takedown of Osama bin Laden,
the leader of terrorist network Al-Qaeda,
after a decade-long search. The hunt and his
death are depicted in "Zero Dark Thirty,"
which was written by Mark Boal and directed by
Kathryn Bigelow. The film centers on fictional
CIA intelligence analyst Maya Harris who
is in the process of finding bin Laden.
Critics up and down the board
agreed that as a thriller,
it's a near perfect example of the genre. It
showed in its score as well, with "Zero Dark
Thirty" achieving an impressive Metacritic score
of 95. Beyond the compliments and glowing praise,
the film is also immersive and memorable, so
it's no wonder it earned its place on this list.
"If you're right, the whole
world’s gonna want in on this."
"A Separation" is a beautiful piece of cinema
from Iran. Written and directed by Asghar Farhadi,
the film is about an estranged couple, Nader and
Simin, who are at odds with each other in regards
to their marriage. Nader is refusing a separation,
resulting in Simin suing Nader for a divorce with
the intention of pursuing a better life for their
daughter abroad. Further complicating things,
Nader finds himself in another court
battle when an abusive act against his
father's pregnant caregiver, Razieh, ends in
a miscarriage and Razieh and her husband sue.
The power of "A Separation" lies in the
compellingly complicated relationships
of these two marriages and the ways in which
they intersect. While it's a character study
at its core, smart filmmaking brings a depth
to the film that makes it feel like much more.
Moreover, the writing articulates
its themes and messages flawlessly,
delivered through the actions of these nuanced
characters. With a Metacritic score of 95,
it has the one key characteristic that arguably
each of the films on this list has: staying power.